it was a sad and somber day yesterday
sadly somber sombrely said another
terribly sad and somber day with Nancy
Pelosi signed the articles of
impeachment and then posed for pictures
and gave out commemorative pens because
that's normal right that's what you do
want to sad in somber occasion you give
out gift bags now you go to a funeral to
hand out gift bags they do a pinata all
right very normal stuff
what's sad and somber is all about and
then very sadly and very somber Lee the
Democrats delivered the articles of
impeachment to the Senate
they formed that the Democrats did in
actual procession much like a procession
you might see if you go to a Catholic
Mass and the priest processes in much
like that two by two they they marched
the folder down the down to the Senate
down the the corridors of the of the
Capitol building it's it's pretty
hilarious now I realize that House
Democrats aren't necessarily in the best
physical shape I don't mean the body
shame and so I understand that but do
they really need nine people to help
carry a folder it's it can't be that
heavy can it and I wonder how much
organization wanted this that's all I
could think what I'm watching is how
much organization how much planning and
prep went into this ahead of time did
they rehearse it did they time their
March they be in the same rhythm as they
were marching how do they decide who to
pair up with or who's in front who I
mean you know that thought went into
this and you see the woman in the back
everybody's paired up two by two there's
a woman straggling behind in the back by
herself I'm guessing that she's sort of
the nerd the hanger-on of the crew and
they tried to leave with leave without
her but then she ran I was wait guys are
you bringing the the articles
impeachment to the Senate yeah oh I want
to come you could also tell that they
really didn't know what to do with their
their faces or their bodies as they were
walking that's what made it awkward it's
hard when you're trying to strike a
balance between sad somber and ecstatic
with triumph and joy it's a really hard
facially that's a really hard balance to
strike and they because those are just
tough great ingredients to find a
harmony way
um but they did their best with it and
hopefully the folder made it there okay
I just wished that for the next
impeachment here's my thought let's do a
whole thing if we want to do this let's
really do it so the next impeachment I
think you should sign the articles down
in Florida and then walk them up ninety
five for a thousand miles
it'll take nine months it'll be a
journey an adventure we'll learn a lot
along the way make some friends it'll be
great
hey let me yeah let me tell you about
ring as we get things started here on
the show you know everyone has a right
to feel safe in their homes and to be
safe it's one of the most basic rights I
think we have is to you know be safe
with our property in our own homes and
if you don't feel safe and secure in
your home then where will you get that
feeling that's why you need a ring rings
mission is to make neighborhoods safer
you might already know about their smart
video doorbells and cameras that protect
millions of people everywhere ring also
helps you stay connected to your home
anywhere in the world so if there's a
package delivery if there's a surprise
visitor you'll get an alert and you'll
be able to see hear and speak to the
person all from your phone so you could
be 3,000 miles away you'd still be able
to do that that's thanks to the HD video
and two-way audio features on ring
devices there's a lot that comes from
this I think it's incredibly convenient
it makes your life easier but for me the
main thing again it's about the peace of
mind that you get from it and you can't
get it you can't put a price tag on a
peace of mind although fortunately ring
has put a price tag on it and the price
tag is extremely affordable as it turns
out in fact as a subscriber you have a
special offer on a ring welcome kit
available right now at ring comm slash
Walsh you want to get that special offer
you got to go to ring comm slash Walsh
the kit includes a video doorbell and a
chime Pro which is just what you need to
start building a ring of security around
your house today go to ring.com slash
Walsh
that's ring comm slash Walsh okay so get
ready
for the most disturbing
thing you've probably heard in a while
somebody emailed this to me brought it
to my attention
Jordan was his name he passed this along
to me it's a post on the reddit forum
child-free now if you're not familiar
with the child free movement that's a
group of people who advocate not just
that people should have no children but
that they should kill the children
they've already conceived so they're
very pro-abortion very anti child and
very open about that they really do hate
children really really hate them this is
not a small group either there's a lot
of these folks out there they're not
just on reddit there are other forums on
the internet Facebook has child-free
groups where these people come together
and they just talk about how much they
absolutely despise children so I want to
read this this one post to you
that Jordan passed along and there are a
few points I want to make about it this
is what it says from a user on reddit
I'm on my way to Planned Parenthood to
purge the two parasites that somehow
implanted into my uterus despite me
being on the pill I can't effing wait to
stop being nauseous and throwing up and
being unable to keep water down I can't
wait to be rid of this hyperemesis
gravidarum that destroyed my Christmas
and ruined my New Year's even is ruining
my life I can't effing wait to be done
with the anxiety of knowing these these
things are in my uterus and knowing that
I will not have to birth dribbling
horror goblins will not have disgusting
leaking blanks censored will not go home
from the hospital in an Appy and with a
stitched up vagina I will not have
postpartum depression or be left
disfigured with stretch marks my
relationship with my significant other
will not be ruined I am dedicating this
double fetus purge to the anti-choice
movement because no matter how hard you
try you will not force us to be your
handmaids happy 2020 and then there are
a whole bunch
of comments hundreds and hundreds of
comments that are even worse than this
if you could believe it but they're all
encouraging her cheering her on I'm not
gonna read them suffice it to say that
the term she called babies dribbling
horror goblins but the term crotch
goblin appears to be the generally
accepted term among these people for
babies that's a term it pops up again
and again
so
a couple of things here few things first
of all
I absolutely reject the rationale that
you hear from a lot of people about this
this kind of stuff
I posted this on Twitter and this was
this was the response from some people
whether they said oh that's just read it
can't get worked up about it it's not
real life no it is it is real life what
do you think this is this is real life
just weird it's not a dream
okay we're not in the matrix
um this is real life what does that even
mean just read it like all of a sudden
something barbaric and horrifying isn't
barbaric and horrifying anymore if it's
at a certain URL why these are human
beings
even if they're not acting like it these
are people actual people writing this
stuff and writing it because that's how
they feel and that's how they think so
these are real people who really feel
this way and are expressing it the fact
that it's just rented or just Twitter or
just YouTube or whatever is by no means
an excuse for them nor is it an excuse
for us to not take it seriously
we've decided that the internet
especially places like Reddit our
morality free zones where atrocious
garbage doesn't matter because it's just
what people do there oh you know that's
just what people do they're not big deal
kids will be kids think about I just
want you to think about and we're so
used to seeing things this way we've
normalized sociopathic truly psychotic
behavior on online the most horrible
things you can imagine the most horrible
of thoughts being expressed we've we've
come to normalize and see is not that
big of a deal if it happens on the
internet but think about how arbitrary
and stupid that is what why who cares if
it's the internet think about how it
would sound if if you told me that you
heard people saying this sort of stuff
to each other in person at let's say
Starbucks what have you worried at
Starbucks and there was a whole bunch of
people sitting around a table talking
about crotch goblins and bragging about
killing babies okay and then you told me
about it and said how horrified you were
and then I said oh that's not real life
it's just Starbucks
you would look at me like I'm crazy what
do you mean it's not real life at
Starbucks did I walk into virtual
reality what are you talking about
the distinction between a Starbucks cafe
and real life would seem rather
arbitrary and unintelligible well it's
the same for this this is real life this
is completely real I'm afraid to say I
hear this a lot as someone who spends a
lot of time on the Internet
unfortunately and you know there have
been as it won't surprise you to learn
there have been I have I have received
my more than I think my fair share of
vile
comments and emails and things from
people and you know I'm so used to it I
think that's part of it we get so used
to it we get numb to it which is a
problem but I get numb to it I get used
to it but every once in a while somebody
will send something to me and they'll
say something that even as as jaded as I
am it makes me go wow that's especially
horrible and then I'll tell somebody
about it and they'll say oh yeah it's
just but you know just the Internet just
what people say
yeah but it shouldn't be though it
shouldn't be what people say
these are still people saying it I I do
not see the distinction between saying
something through this forum and saying
it any other way whether it's verbally
whether it's ridicule written on a
loose-leaf piece of paper and left at
your doorstep what difference does it
make it's still a person saying it right
the
rationale or excuse you often here is
that well people have always been like
this it's nothing new the only
difference is that now we know about it
because of the internet and that's true
I think that but that's part of the
problem the Internet has provided a
forum for people to in the safety of
anonymity to air their most depraved and
disgusting thoughts and pretty soon
these communities start to crop up
communities of people who have bonded
together just by the fact that they all
share the same depraved disgusting
thoughts that's the only bond that's
that is the defining thing about their
community they have formed a community
around it
that they all think this horrible thing
or they have this horrible interest or
proclivity or whatever it is and and
they form a club around it and the
effect is that they encourage each other
in it and they dive deeper into their
own depravity together and other people
who've maybe had similar thoughts or
close to similar thoughts see this and
it's normalized for them and they think
oh it's okay because we are inclined as
people to think and I think this is this
is part of the issue here is that as
people we are inclined to think that
things are okay if other people are
doing them or saying as much as we were
told as as as kids by our parents you
know just because you're friends are
jumping off a bridge doesn't mean you
should too the fact is if you see a
bunch of people jumping off a bridge
you're probably gonna think well I guess
it's okay to jump off that bridge that's
how we are
with our most shameful thoughts if we
see we'd go online and we see other
people saying the same thing we think oh
it must not be that bad then
now in past times a person would have a
depraved and disgusting thought would
tell nobody because there'd be no safe
place to divulge it there be there no
way there'd be no way for them to say it
anonymously and so they don't say it at
all and they feel shame for their
thoughts which they should feel and they
suppress it which they should suppress
it and maybe eventually they succeed in
moving on from it or maybe not but maybe
they do so there have always been
parents who felt horrible things about
their kids it's just that in the past
there was nowhere for them to go and
brag about it there was nowhere for them
to go and be made to feel comfortable
with these thoughts now there is
and if you go to this child freeform is
it one of the other I mean if you you
can't spend a lot of time there you just
wouldn't be able to stomach it but I was
looking at a few other posts and there's
a lot of also parents who've actually
had their kids and hate their kids
babies I mean I saw one post wrote from
a woman with a baby and talking about
how much she hates her baby and wishes
the baby was dead and she never had the
baby
now again have there always been parents
who felt this way about their kids sure
but the only difference is they couldn't
go to a community and have these
thoughts normalized and be celebrated
and encouraged in it
whereas in the past they might have had
to think to themselves wow this is
really terrible that I feel this way
this is wrong I should not feel this way
about my kids there is something wrong
with me I am ashamed I should be ashamed
it is shameful I feel this way because I
am a selfish disgusting person and I
shouldn't be that way I need to change
myself
that's how it used to be not now though
the third thing to anyone tempted to
think that what I just read is not
representative of the pro-abortion
movement you are absolutely wrong
and as pro-lifers
I think pro-lifers can tend to be timid
about a lot of things unfortunately not
all pro-lifers but this is a problem
among some pro-lifers is timidity
and I think it's been a fatal problem
for the pro-life movement for a long
time
and pro some parlors get timid about
this to it they don't want to use
examples like this cuz they say yeah but
that's not now we I don't want to paint
with a broad brush that's not me of
course that yes this is representative
of the pro bortion movement what I just
read to you
and that's the real value of a forum for
for us anyway the value of a forum or a
community like this is that it you see
the pro-abortion movement without the
mask without the makeup without the
euphemisms in the sanitary language
sixty million babies have been killed in
this country okay do you really think
the abortion movement can administer a
slaughter of that degree and can rack up
that kind of body count without a lot of
people in the movement feeling exactly
this way about babies of course many of
them feel this way about babies they're
killing them that's often how you feel
about things that you kill
so I don't want to hear any nonsense
about the weather this is extreme case
extreme cases 60 million
think of those CMP undercover tapes of
Planned Parenthood officials the Center
for medical progress Dave daleiden think
about what we saw in those videos
remember how the the pro the Planned
Parenthood officials talked about the
babies they were killing they were
laughing about it and joking about it
this is normal for them
it's not normal in the sense of good
like we're trying to distinguish
yesterday on the show it would you know
with the different definitions of normal
but normal in the sense of common in the
pro-bush but yes this is common
the the abortion movement encourages
explicitly women to see their babies as
parasites
now I'm not say
every woman who gets an abortion feels
this way or talks this way about
the child that they're going to kill
I'm saying that this is the attitude
towards unborn children at the abortion
movement purposefully inculcates
um
that's this is the if if we're killing
60 million babies it means that we're
treating those babies like parasites
and this is how people feel about
parasites and this is how you talk about
them
and by the way
as the as pro-lifers have been pointing
out for a long time if if this is the
attitude that we're encouraging people
to have about unborn children inevitably
they're also going to have that attitude
about born children there's no
difference at all between an infant the
post that I saw was a woman talking
about our infant I think of eight or
nine months talk about how much she
hates the baby
well there's no difference between an
infant of 8 or 9 months and an infant in
the womb there's no difference it's the
same thing it's literally the same
person right
so if we are encouraging women to see
and mothers to see their own children as
parasites and cancers in the womb it's
it's not that hard to see how how that
feeling for some women might carry over
into
after the birth
it's not gonna suddenly just go away
in fact it probably uh will probably be
exacerbated by you know the fact that
infants are really difficult to take
care of I mean we've had four of them we
had two at the same time so you know we
know what it's like it's not easy to
have an infant
takes a lot of hard work and a lot of
sacrifice
in this self-centered culture the
self-obsessed culture
top of it babies are literally treated
like parasites and murdered to the tune
of 60 million in the span of just a few
decades
um with all of those factors coming
together it's it's it's not hard to see
eventually that's going to bleed over
into a hatred of and resentment towards
children born children as well and I
think we're seeing
and I am NOT
I am I'm worried about where this heads
you go to that this chat these
child-free people how do you think you
think they would have any problem with
infanticide
we have to stop treating this like some
crazy dystopian you know hypothetical
there are many cultures in the world
that I've had that heavily that I've had
legalized
infanticide and all of the arguments for
abortion would apply just as much to
infanticide and if you have that kind of
hatred for unborn children then again
you're gonna have that kind of hatred
for infants too there's no reason not to
it's the same person
and these child-free people I mean if
you were to ask them you think they have
any problem with the way they talk about
they call them goblins not just not just
unborn children but born children they
refer to as goblins you think they would
have any problem if it was if it was
legal to just kill a nine month old do
you think they'd have any problem with
that no they wouldn't
you
so that's where we're
you know I I do believe that's that's
where that's where the left will we'll
take this if we don't stop them
we've already heard it from Ralph
Northam we've heard it you know
increasingly
all right
let's move on because it's hard to dwell
on this for too long by the way if
you're not already a subscriber to the
daily water you're really missing out
and right now using promo code Walsh
you'll get 10% off any plan that you
choose head over to daily wire comm
slash subscribe and pick the plans that
are right for you
head over for as little as ten bucks a
month members get our articles ad free
you get access to all of our live
broadcasts you get the entire show
library you get three hours of Ben
Shapiro every day and you get select
bonus content you get access to the
mailbag and you get just a ton of stuff
plus our yard new all-access tear gets
you live online Q&A discussions with me
Ben Shapiro Andrew clave and Michael
Knowles plus our daily wire writers we
let them up from the cave to come up
into the to the sunlight to answer some
questions every once a while and don't
forget you also get the greatest of all
beverage vessels the leftist tears
tumblr that's daily wire calm slash
subscribe okay I wanted to mention this
if you remember we talked about few days
ago Stephen King was on the verge of
cancellation for having the gall to
suggest that maybe Awards like you know
Oscars should be given out based on
merits and based on the quality of the
work and not based on diversity quotas
here's what he said actually a few days
ago he said
as a writer I'm allowed to nominate in
just three categories Best Picture Best
Adapted Screenplay and Best Original
Screenplay for me the diversity issue as
it applies to the individual actors and
directors anyway did not come up that
said I would never consider diversity in
matters of art only quality it seems to
me that to do otherwise would be wrong
okay and you just knew what's gonna
happen next
of course the
decends how dare you how dare you
suggest that we award people based on
the quality of their work and not and
not based on their skin color or their
genitalia how dare you how offensive and
it only took what it took
well it took less than a day for Stephen
King to come back and start groveling
and then he said only you know hours
later he said the most important thing
we can do as artists and creative people
is make sure everyone has the same fair
shot regardless of sex color orientation
right now such people are badly
underrepresented and not only in the
arts you can't win awards if you're shut
out of the game so there's no apology
it's just more he's pretending he's
gonna pretend that never happened
and he's he's back he's back on the
script
groveling bowing before the pc altar now
first of all of course this is totally
nonsense the idea that
you know the women gay people black
people are underrepresented on TV or in
movies come on that's that's I I don't I
don't see that as a you you're gonna
have to actually rather than just
asserting that you're gonna have to
actually prove that somebody wants to
take the time to tabulate this
then go ahead and do it but I think if
you if you do that what you're gonna
find is that actually it's probably
about where it should be in terms of
representation and and it seems like
especially on TV on network TV these
days I mean pretty much every show has
at least one gay character so probably
there's over representation when you
consider to consider how many gay people
are actually are in America in terms of
percentages and then how often you have
such characters on TV
it's at least gonna be proportional but
probably I would think over there might
there might even be some
over-representation but in the end it
doesn't matter of course
point of an award is to is to give an
award to the to the based on merit based
on quality as Stephen King originally
pointed out and also you know you've got
storytellers who are telling the stories
that they want to tell
if you think that there should be more
stories that feature women or gay people
or whatever then then you tell that
story
I mean what what is the implication here
I saw there was someone some someone in
media I think not just this one person
but there was a tweet that went semi
viral from a woman complaining about
1917
and saying that saying that you know I
don't I don't have a problem you know I
understand that that in World War one
we're talking about trench warfare there
weren't a lot of women down in the
trenches and so this is gonna be a movie
about about men but she said I don't
understand why we have to keep telling
these stories
well maybe we're telling these stories
if by these stories she means like war
movies because of these are some of the
most consequential moments in history
and these are moments full of drama and
heroism and so these are stories that
speak to people and always have for
thousands of years we've been telling
stories about battles and battles that
have been fought and wars have been
waged for that reason
but besides which what are you what are
you saying exactly
are you saying that you know Sam Mendes
made that movie which again is a great
movie if you haven't seen it are you
saying that what he he he really wants
to tell this story and it's an important
story but he shouldn't tell it in order
to be fair to women is that what you're
implying
extrapolate on those thoughts a little
bit what's your point
this is a story he's a storyteller this
is a story that he thought was
meaningful and he was right I think it's
meaningful to I think most people do and
so he told it
is that really the calculation that you
want artists to make
should artists be making that
calculation is that good for art
to have an artist who says to himself or
herself
this story is meaningful to me I really
want to tell it yeah but I'm not going
to because I don't know there might be
too many straight men in it
you think that's good for art
for artists to self-censor in that way
based on some notion of some vague
arbitrary notion of fairness and
demographic proportionality
all right let's go to emails Matt wall
show at gmail.com Matt wall show at
gmail.com email address this is from
Josh says hi Matt I realize a lot of
people get their news from social media
snapchats
prevailing news outlet is Daily Mail
this this was one of their big headlines
on their snap it gives a link what do
you think is the study credible the
study Josh links to it has the blaring
headline nearly 100 percent of US women
who got abortions say it was the right
decision five years after undergoing the
procedure study finds now before we saw
a hundred percent of women but nearly
100 percent of women do not regret their
abortion after five years according to
this study before we before we even read
anything about the study or consider it
in any depth at all we already know this
can't be true we it cannot be true
you cannot possibly find 100% agreement
among people on anything even less can
you find a hundred percent of people who
agree that they have no regrets about a
particular thing even less ifs if it's
something like abortion that we're
talking about now even if I believed
that abortion is good I still wouldn't
expect anything close to 100 percent of
women to not regret doing it
you know I wouldn't expect a hundred
percent of people who I don't know had
omelettes for breakfast this morning to
not regret having the omelette people
have regrets it's a normal human thing
there's no way you're gonna find nearly
a hundred percent agreement or a hundred
percent of people who are confident and
have no regrets about about a particular
choice no matter what the choice is
but we understand that something like
abortion even if again even if you think
it's fine you're wrong but even if you
think it's fine you must at least
understand that it's a it's a
consequential very emotional decision
so there are gonna be regrets this would
be like if I claimed
a study saying that nearly a hundred
percent of couples that get divorced
don't regret it now even if you think
that most abortion divorces are
justified and and you know you don't see
any problem with divorce you must also
realize that it is the kind of thing
that a large percentage of people tend
to regret
kind of thing
so the same would be for abortion and
then when you have on top of that of
course you know as I have I've talked to
personally talk to I or heard from a
great great great many women who deeply
and profoundly regret their abortions
so we know those women exists you can
easily talk to them
talk to anyone who works at a crisis
pregnancy center or Pregnancy Resource
Center
and and most of these places have post
abortive counseling and ask them
their poster board of counseling
sessions are not empty
these women come in I don't think
they're all lying
by the way if you showed me a study
that a hundred percent of parents who
have children don't regret it I would
say BS to that to a hundred percent
no but I'm supposed to believe that a
hundred percent of women who kill their
children don't regret it that that's
that's obviously absurd so I'm going
into this with extreme skepticism but
let's take a look at it reading from the
article says deciding to terminate a
pregnancy is certainly a difficult
decision for most but the majority of
women also report they believe they made
the right decision immediately after
aborting new University of California
South Carolina a South new University of
California San Francisco research found
that they almost universally feel the
same way five years down the line
further debunking notions that abortion
harms women
which by the way that doesn't even
follow even if this was true it would
not at all prove that abortion doesn't
harm women
for a person to be harmed by something
that they don't regret
we could all come up with it with
examples of stuff
um having so already this article is
just a is a is a is a silly propaganda
piece but we'll continue having negative
emotions after what for some is a
difficult decision a big deal in their
lives experience some guilt and negative
emotions I would be shocked if we didn't
find that UCSF study co-author dr.
Corrine Rocca told Daily Mail negative
emotions are not something to legislate
it's natural and her study published in
social science and medicine found that
these emotions fade over time added dr.
Rocca I think it's really encouraging to
find that negative emotions go down over
time
she and her team conducted a total of 11
interviews with nearly a thousand
American women who underwent abortions
over the course of five years following
their procedures
at first more than half of the women
interviewed as part of the turn away
study a data collection project designed
to track the short and long-term effects
of abortion of abortion on a woman's
well-being had positive emotions a week
after their procedures twenty percent
said they didn't feel much about the
procedure while seventeen percent said
they had negative emotions about their
abortions as their lives moved on post
abortion the number of women who had
little or no feelings about their
abortions increased significantly by the
time it was five years out just six
percent had any vestige vestigial
negative feelings at the five-year mark
ninety nine percent of those women said
that having the abortion had been the
right decision for them
dr. Rocca also notes that there's a
small proportion of people who regret
any decision they make there's no part
of me that wants to reduce the struggle
of people who come to a place where they
wish they have made a different decision
and I hope they get the counseling they
need but it's misguided to then let let
that guide the overwhelming majority of
people who seek this care okay so big
problems as expected first is that the
author of the study dr. Rocca is clearly
biased it's obvious that she's
pro-abortion
that she wants women to not regret the
abortion she has opinions about public
policy she's commenting on legislation
so this is it's just not science this is
advocacy science cannot be partisan if
you're doing real research you can't go
into it with your pom-poms out rooting
for one side if you do that it negates
the the conclusions completely this kind
of thing is an embarrassment but these
like every study you see with these I've
talked about it plenty of times in the
past these these kinds of studies that
get the blaring headlines and that are
used by one side or the other to prove
one point or the other when you actually
read the studies you find so often it
seems like in the majority of cases to
begin with
these studies are conducted by partisans
who are looking to prove a point and if
that is how a study is conducted it is
useless you can you can learn nothing
from it other than the the fact that you
know a lot of people don't know how to
conduct actual scientific studies and
then we get to the real kicker which the
Daily Mail article buries several
paragraphs into the article writing in
the Catholic Medical Association's
journal anti-abortionist
anti-abortionist how do you like that
dr. David Reardon noted that less than a
third of the 3,000 women who offered the
chance who were offered the chance to
make $50 by participating in the study
actually stuck with it with more
dropping out with each round of
interviews
as studies go a thousand participants
isn't a huge number even when it's
controlled to be representative of the
country as the turn away study is so
there you go when you hear that Oh
bye-bye five years out all the women say
they don't regret the abortions that's
because most of them have dropped out of
the study which so they don't tell you
that right they don't tell you Daily
Mail knows that they have to include
that information somewhere if they're
going to if this is going to be some
semblance of a of an actual news article
you can't leave that out completely but
what they do is they give you the
headline they give you everything about
the study and at the very bottom they
include the little tidbit that negates
everything you just read but they know
that most people aren't going to get in
down to that tidbit not gonna read it
most people will just see the headline
and take that at face value and of the
people who click it most will probably
read about one paragraph at most I mean
the average you know article online is
read for about twenty seconds or
something like that and so the Daily
Mail knows that and so at the very
bottom it's kind of like there's an
asterisks at the very bottom it says by
the way nothing that you just read means
anything
yeah the people who stick with it feel
that way because that's why they stuck
with it but the majority have dropped
out of the study why did they drop out
so you have a thousand people - only a
thousand people to begin with
so this is this this cannot be a
representative sample it's way too small
way too small to be a representative
sample of the country or of posta Board
of women at large so this this blaring
headline makes a statement about one
about about what 100 percent of post
abortive women think and then you find
out that oh they only talk to a thousand
of them
and
of that thousand most of them didn't
finish the study
now why might someone refuse to take to
be a part of this study in the first
place why might they drop out in the
middle well I could think of one big
reason it might be because this was a
traumatic experience and they don't want
to talk about it
so of that of that chunk of people the
the majority who either didn't want to
take the study or didn't finish it it's
it's it's safe to speculate that a large
number of them probably do regret their
abortions and that's why they didn't
want to take the study or at least one
of the reasons why
so this study is is just completely
bogus and
and pointless and useless
I did yeah and I did I went and gue
checked on Google and of course the
medias picked this up and they're there
spreading it all around it oh look at
that
no women regret their abortions what do
you know I mean we've been hearing from
women for years who say they regret
their abortions turns out according to
the study those women don't exist there
are figments of our imagination
this is from jeremiah says matt dead-ass
loved the show bruh
in all seriousness i wanted to get your
thoughts on this story assuming she was
really kicked out for the reason her
family says what do you think about it
and then jeremiah links to a story in
the USA Today about a girl who was
supposedly kicked out of her Christian
school for having a rainbow cake on her
birthday again now we're back to the
theme of skepticism you know we go into
this with skepticism that's the claim
anyway me and I've seen this story on
social media maybe you've seen it the
claim is she well I'll just read from
USA Today read a little bit us it says a
Christian school in Louisville expelled
a student last week after her family
said school officials discovered the
girl had celebrated her birthday with a
rainbow themed cake
Kimberly Alford told the courier-journal
that until January 6 her 15 year old
daughter had been a freshman at with
Whitefield Academy a private school that
serves students in preschool through
12th grade that's when Alpha
said she received an email from
Whitefield Academy's head of school
bruce jacobson explaining how her
daughter was being expelled immediately
due to a post on social media
alfred had recently posted a photo on
her facebook page showing her daughter
celebrating her birthday in late
december at a texas roadhouse restaurant
in the photo the girl is wearing a
sweater featuring a rainbow design and
sitting by a colorful rainbow themed
cake okay so uh I wish some I wish
people at some point would learn the
lesson about not jumping to conclusions
with things like this obviously if this
girl was actually expelled for having a
multicolored birthday cake in her own
house or at a restaurant in her own time
with pictures posted to social media
then that's totally insane of course
that's absolutely asinine and crazy and
unjust if that's what happened I don't
think anyone would defend it
but that's part of the reason I'm
skeptical about it
when there's when there's a dispute
between two people or two groups of
people in this case the daughter and the
mom verse 2 school and the version of
the story you get makes one side seem
unquestionably in the right and the
other side seem absolutely crazy like
nobody could be on their side well
that's already a red flag that you're
probably not getting the whole story
maybe you are right sometimes you know
some sometimes disputes between people
are that simple there's a simple good
guy too simple bad guy some put most of
the time though that's not the case
because people have a need to feel like
they're in the right
and so at least the people in the school
that made this decision they probably
feel like they have to have some reason
other than a rainbow cake I'm thinking
if you talk to them they they probably
would have would have more to say than
just that probably stands to reason
should be a red flag and there's some
skepticism we should think well you know
is that really the whole story if it is
crazy but is it
now as it turns out the school has
indicated that there have been a series
of what they call lifestyle violations
from what I saw the school won't confirm
that this really was that this rainbow
cake was the last lifestyle straw that
broke the camel's back as it were so we
have to you know so so we don't know we
have to remember that that schools are
often at a disadvantage in cases like
this because they can't talk openly
about disciplinary issues involving
students whereas the student and the
family can say whatever they want but
legally and for liability issues the
school is not as free to talk about it
and justify the decision they made and
that's so that's that's you know they've
got a hand tied behind the back in that
case so I you know I don't know is is is
is the the answer I have no idea
I just think there's probably more to
the story
than this
there's not okay well and this school
should be totally ashamed of itself
if there is then then we would have to
know what the rest of the story is I do
believe it is general principle private
schools have a right to admit whoever
they want and kick out whoever they want
and especially if they have rules and
they lay it out in the handbook and they
say these are our rules if you sign on
to those rules no matter what the rules
are if you sign on to them then you sign
on to them and it's up to you to follow
them you can't sign on to the rules and
then decide a few years later oh you
know what actually those rules are
stupid I don't want to listen to them oh
you can decide that but then it's up to
you to just leave the school and go
somewhere else
so that's that's a general feeling I
have about controversies like this
especially when it comes to Christian
schools who you know we it's it's every
once in a while we get these stories
about usually though it's it's a
Christian school you know fires a
teacher or something because they find
out they're in a gay relationship or
whatever it is but again that's if
that's part of the rule if they're
trying to maintain this certain identity
and they believe it's important for
everybody involved in the school to live
according to and believe biblical
teachings which i think is reasonable
for a christian school to want that just
like i think it'd be reasonable for a
jewish school to want all everyone there
to be devout Jews and for a Muslim
school to you know want a similar thing
in respect to Islam I mean that's that's
reasonable to me
now kicking someone out over a cake
would not be reasonable
if there's something in the handbook
that says you know thou shalt not eat
from a rainbow cake
I'm gonna be a silly rule but if you
signed on to it I guess it's up to you
to follow it but I kind of doubt that
that's the case and you know what we'll
probably never know
you and I as Outsiders who are not
involved in this who probably live
States away from where it happened don't
know anybody involved don't know the
family don't know the girl don't know
the school for free for you and I will
probably never know who was in the right
who was in the wrong or what really
happened or what the whole story is
and that's okay because we don't need to
know
and another the problem problems with
the internet is that there's no such
thing as a local story anymore
everything is national news
if it goes viral of a small local little
incident goes viral
now it's national news and everybody's
talking about it and everybody's
concerned with
because there there are a lot of things
that happen that are not really suited
for national consumption they don't
involve anybody else they it's not
relevant to us
there's no way that we could you know we
there's our contributions or our
opinions cannot have any value
whatsoever because we have no idea
what's going on the issue is too remote
and it involves people and things that
we don't know anything about
but you know because
on social media we think that we have to
have an opinion about everything when
sometimes maybe we should just say there
I don't know
I think that's that's an okay
responsiveness I don't know I hope the
people involved work it out
I hope that the best result you know the
best possible result is what happens
that's what I hope I have nothing else
to say all right thanks for the email
again the email addresses matt walsh
show at gmail.com and we'll wrap it up
there thank somebody for watching thanks
for listening Godspeed
the Matt Walsh show is produced by Sean
Hampton executive producer Jeremy boring
senior producer Jonathan hey supervising
producer Mathis Glover supervising
producer Robert Stirling technical
producer Austin Stephens editor Donovan
Fowler audio mixer Robin Fenderson the
Matt Walsh show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 20 a
giddy Nancy Pelosi pretends to be summer
while signing the official impeachment
resolution against President Trump and
simultaneously doling out souvenir pens
to her jackal colleagues
meanwhile Vladimir Putin moves to
consolidate power and yet another blow
to representative government in Russia
we will examine why and how democracy
fails then Trump wins big on the trade
war with China
huge huge News CNN releases the war in
Boerne exchange and finally the mailbag
check it out on the Michael Knowles show
[Music]